سيدان تبدأ اليوم الثاني من
وقف إطلاق النار لمدة 72 ساعة بين القوات المسلحة في
مجموعة شبه عسكرية ، لكن حتى الآن
فشل الاتفاق تمامًا في وقف
القتال بين المدنيين وأفادت الأمم المتحدة بمزيد من
الاشتباكات في اليوم الأول من الهدنة.  يقول
موظف من
وكالة الهجرة التابعة للأمم المتحدة بشكل عام إن أكثر من 400
شخص لقوا مصرعهم منذ
بدء القتال الأسبوع الماضي.يقول
الصليب الأحمر إن العنف
منع المجموعة من تقديم
المساعدات التي تشتد الحاجة إليها.  أعلن مقاتلو القوات شبه العسكرية السودانية في وقت سابق
أنهم مستعدون لإعادة
فتح المطارات جزئيًا على الصعيد الوطني ،
وقالوا إن هذا سيسمح
لدول أخرى بإجلاء مواطنيها بأمان.
تراقب عن كثب
الوضع المضطرب واستعداداتهم
جارية لإجلاء محتمل ،
وأكدت وزارة الخارجية لشبكة CNN أن
مواطنًا أمريكيًا توفي في السودان على الرغم من
عدم توفير الظروف المحيطة بالوفاة ، وحذر البيت الأبيض يوم
الجمعة من أن المواطنين العاديين يجب ألا
يتوقعوا.  حكومة الولايات المتحدة
لإخراجهم من السودان
عندما يتعلق الأمر بالسودان ، هذا تحذير
تحذير من المستوى 4 قدمناه
لهم منذ عدة أشهر
لإخبار الأمريكيين الموجودين هناك بشكل أساسي
بالمغادرة إذا كان بإمكانهم وكذلك عدم
سفر الأمريكيين بعدم السفر  للسودان
لذلك كنا واضحين جدًا بشأن ذلك مرة أخرى
إنه ليس إجراءً معياريًا